c'est au centre
ben oui évidemment elles sont hors sol
parce que elle elle vivent pas dans le
même monde que nous et encore moi je me
mets dans dans un niveau qui est moi
aussi hors sol mais je suis moins hors
sol que c'est sarlat moi je fais
j'essaie de faire attention parce que je
vis dans la vraie vie je vais faire mes
courses au supermarché je fais non
guillemets et
au team à siffler et et dans ma famille
on a des métiers normaux on voit et je
vois que je vois exactement ce que c'est
et moi j'ai peur du lendemain et je fais
attention et j'ai mon enfant à élever
jeu et je mets de côté je suis pas
dispendieuse qua non mais c'est quoi
alors je suis vraiment que je sais que
toi ça te rend fou pas assez compliqué à
la elle a eu sa vie où elle faisait des
julie lescaut à 130 milles 140 milles
l'épisode si je dis pas de conneries
donc forcément pour être dix mille euros
mais quand elle parle a annoncé 120000
euros faut dix ans pour gagner 120
millions et elle a dit quand ils n'y
arrivent pas une dix mille euros mais si
des procès d'intention cessé de tomber
al pays faisait face à je cite a déjà
payé un épais ce n'est pas un minimum
quelques mois le record
bien de quel montant elle voit quelques
moments dans la vie il faut
dire que je ne connais pas mais tous les
gens
passaient des enfants il se met tous
ensemble moi dans mon nom dans - bruce
et les enfants qui se met tous ensemble
belles images et en sons pour payer
leurs moments parce qu'on la sort examen
de alors maire voit presse il vous faut
dix mille euros par mois tant mieux pour
être s'il lui faut dix mille euros par
mois je sais que ou moi une faute 2000
par mois l'heureux 1200 la fête s'il ya
quelqu'un qui se la pètent pas on peut
tous les prochains vous voyez de ne pas
l'aimer aussi à quelqu'un qui se la pète
pas et qui a le coeur sang s'amasser
mais à l on peut pas entendre
qu'est-ce
que vous l'aviez jamais mais qui tombe
dès qu'ils prennent cette s'emballe par
mois ou 800 balles par mois ils
entendent ça il faut diminuer
oui sans ballack y 800 balle a dit me
dis-je à ces dames est rien c'est pas
chez toi faut arrêter d'être démago
deuxième chien femme de défoncer cette
faille risque parce que parce qu'elle
avait simplement répondu à une question
les réseaux c'est vrai que certains
disaient n'importe quoi elle a
l'honnêteté de répondre à une question
et tout le monde lui tombe dessus et
ensuite faut arrêter l'hypocrisie dix
mille euros c'est énormément d'argent
c'est vrai il ya très peu de gens qui
gagnent ça mais il ya aussi énormément
de stars qui gagne dix vingt trente fois
cela par mois donc voilà faut arrêter
l'hypocrisie elle a effectivement
énormément de charles et je pense pas
qu'avec dix mille euros elles vivent la
vida loca je pense pas qu'elle prenne
des jets privés je pense pas qu'elle est
l'un des restaurants gastronomiques tous
les jours lui c'est beaucoup d'argent
était
d'accord mais c'est votre réalité si
elle si elle a besoin de dix mille euros
c'est qu'à s'est mis dans une saison
soit survenir dès demain a permis alors
c'est ce que je vous interdis j'ai envie
d'habiter avenue victoire tu es là on
verra bien combien de gens sous tu me
l'ont bien tu crois tout cumulé je dois
être à 5000 euros mais c'est beaucoup
des phrases et revoilà donc ça m'a dit
il c'est une petite 6 le stade
j'avais besoin de dix mille ans avec ce
que je veux c'est un gars de ma vie de
mary go je veux rouler en marche mais je
roulais emploi mais ces voyages partout
et je me mette un train de déchets ou de
la ville bernard montiel ces loteries
tout au long
de la vie en groupe c'est le train de
vie qu'elle s'est mis vous avez
vous pouvez pas en tant que dix mille
euros c'est pas beaucoup d'argent ils
les auront jamais dadis à
l'environnement mais arrêtez de parler
quand on se dirait vraiment mais je suis
absolument d'accord avec une démagogie à
l'envers de la même manière que moi je
trouve qu'elle ne se plaint pas elle
expliqué fait de la pédagogie moraliser
l'ehpad mais tout le monde n'a pas les
moyens de mettre ses parents dans
l'ehpad il ya plein de gens qui gardent
leurs mains leur maman ou leurs grandes
galeries d'art j'ai absolument pas nous
égarer jours c'est justement sur
solidaire c'est par plaisir de
pouvoir payer mais elle dit pas le
contraire elle dit j'ai je dois payer
les pattes pour ma mère donc voilà c'est
environ 3500 à 4000 euros isabelle joly
du rouleau les détenus ici c'est hier
cinq ou dix ans à sa belle et joyeuse
des français même ça sent le moment
guillaume c'est dégueulasse avec procès
d'intention pendant 17 ans de faim nous
fait il est diplômé en peuple
[Applaudissements]
de luri relaxer sur les problèmes de
coût et de pouvoir d'achat dont moi je
voudrais savoir et mon nom concrètement
combien tu dépenses tous les mets moi je
t'ai de moi je discutais
connectez vous verrez ce très bon très
bon je vais être content voilà j'ai non
seulement pour mon salaire de
chauffeur-livreur 1900 balle par mois
c'est d'accord ou paraître ce que je
fais ici je les ai toujours dit ici j'ai
dit je mets de côté je rembourse ma
maison presque à la retraite quand je
vais avoir mes mille cinq cents balles
de retraite je ne veux plus avoir de
loyer à payer quand je t'ai dit tout à
l'heure entre 4500 et 5000 balle part
offerte elle s'est en plus c'est fini
art est jeté et non sélectionneur
je travaillais du lundi au dimanche sans
arrêt je faisais 150 euros bruts parle
pas par émission sur arte elle dit c'est
pas dix mille euros bassima non c'est
pas dix mille euros j'ai jamais eu dix
meilleurs audios p